welcome to
another dr sadler's honest review this
is a series
in which i examine mostly
recent books having to do with practical
philosophy
philosophy as it's lived and applied so
that includes
works in leisure self-help
organizational
matters and and all sorts of other
things as well
the book that i have today to review
is one that i'm actually very happy to
have received it is this recently
released translation and edition let's
call it
of the selected writings of pierre ado
subtitled philosophy as practice
and it is translated by matthew sharp
and federico testa and it's uh
it's it's quite excellent i will say um
it retails for around 30 it's hard to
find any price on it but that seems to
be
what i've discovered so i'm going to
tell you quite a bit about this book and
and i want to say from the very
beginning
that if you're interested in philosophy
broadly speaking
pure ado in particular or this notion
as philosophy as a way of life you
you definitely want to get your hands on
this
i like to begin these reviews by talking
about the three
s's giving a summary of the work talking
about the style that you're going to
encounter and giving an overview of the
structure
so let's start with a bit of a summary
if you're going to
explain this in just a few words you
would say
so these are indeed selected writings of
this great philosopher
a historian of philosophy somebody who's
bringing back to the four
ways of of doing philosophy that are
often
left out of academic philosophy as we do
it now
and these essays range over a number of
different
topics they're quite well selected i
would say
you know to give you a good sense not
only of
what pura does projects and notice i use
the plural there because he had a number
of different
uh interconnected projects in the
history of philosophy and philosophy as
a way of life
but also you know you'll learn quite a
bit about
ancient philosophy and its schools and
and what they were
interested in by reading through this
work so you know summary of it this is
this is a set of translations and i'm
going to talk about the translation
matter a little bit later and it's
a selection of some of his
previously untranslated works that
english readers will definitely want to
have
so that's summary let's talk about the
style now here's where it gets kind of
interesting right
it's a translation so we're dealing with
essentially two sets of people's styles
one set is pirado himself
and the other set are the translators
who are taking
a doze french although involving a lot
of also latin and greek stuff
and putting it into our english
language and as somebody who's been a
translator translating from
each of those languages but primarily
french i know how difficult
good translation can be and
how um you know what the task is is like
as a translator this is a good
translation
the this is very readable
you know it is it it's not simply
academic prose i would say this is this
is some really good
english and you know that's in part
reflective of
a doe's own french you know
as opposed to quite a few this will be a
little bit of a digression
quite a few french writers post 1950 on
who are in love with their capacity to
play around with the language adele is
much more like
pre-1950 really clear
french pros that he's he's carrying
forward and so you know you've got
something that
is as a product
quite good and i will say something too
about the the work itself so
there's translators notes in here i
always like to see that because if
there's something
that is a little bit questionable or
fishy
i want it picked out that's more my
preference than anybody else
and then there's end notes at the end of
each chapter that give you a doze
on things that he's telling you about
you know
the references or little side notes and
and
things like that so that's an important
part of the
uh the translation apparatus and the
style
let's talk about the structure so it's a
you know selected writing selected
essays and it begins with a
a forward very short by arnold davidson
and danielle
laurenzini and then there's a long
introduction called situating a doe
today
by um matthew sharp and i think that
this is actually
quite good it is 25 pages uh
actually 27 pages including all of the
notes
some of the notes are actually worth
reading because there's some some good
discussions in there and this provides
you with a nice
overview of you know why
we want to study this guy ado who's
studying
other people and what the the importance
of ado
is at present i'll i'll return to that
in a bit later on
here and then we have um the book is
divided up into a number of different
sections
so part one is key parameters
and this includes four essays some of
the essays are
longer than others some are quite
lengthy some are quite short
the first one smart starts up my books
and my research you know ado
is giving you a summary of what he's up
to i think that's a great you know
place to start there's a discussion in
the ancient philosophers
follows follows next uh is chapter two
right and that is going to be um
so it's a review that that's engaging
with
another person and ado is sort of
revealing his own
views along the way then we have this
really important chapter ancient
philosophy and ethics or
practice he talks about spiritual
exercises
a key idea running throughout ado's
works
and he's giving you all sorts of
references to
ancient philosophy in in doing this
talks about philosophy as practice
in opposition to philosophical discourse
in in
hellenistic philosophy philosophical
discourse and practice in aristotle in
plato something else that we're going to
come back to
as a sort of controversial point
then there's uh this really interesting
piece on the oral teaching of
plato and this
is uh a doze you could say
intervention against those who say we
can only look at the texts
we shouldn't think about the you know uh
oral situation of of this discussion
and he's he's you know he's talking
about how people actually
read things back then and what the
relation between orality and writing
was so that's the first part these are
all kind of preliminary
things and then there's a part two
called aspects it has a really nice
chapter
on conversion or you know changing
one's one's mind one's way of life
some good comparative work there one of
the essays i really like
the divisions of the parts of philosophy
and antiquity
how do we actually make sense out of
how philosophy gets
parceled out right it's different in
ancient times than it is now
what what's going on there was there a
reason for that
then there's a similar chapter
philosophy dialectic and rhetoric in
antiquity
sort of charting out what how these were
connected with each other
uh in in the way that they thought about
it
so then we moved to part three part
three
is focused on nature this is actually
something that as sharp points out but i
think other people
have pointed out as well ado
has a penchant
for focusing in on where the references
to nature mean developing one's human
nature
in relation to the cosmos he thought
that was something really
central to ancient philosophy and i
think he's right about that so there's
this great
uh essay here ancient man and nature
sort of laying those things out he's got
another really interesting one here the
gene
genius of place in ancient greece does
place matter
then we get to part four figures what do
we mean by figures
um you know essentially people so the
first
the first uh essay here chapter 10
begins with the figure of the sage in
greek and roman antiquity
a lot of back and forth discussion about
you know how the different schools
understood the sage and then there's
this really interesting piece
physics is spiritual exercise or
pessimism and optimism in marcus
aurelius
marcus aurelius we don't usually think
of as
the sage although he was attempting to
to get himself
you know on on the path to that he's a
very busy guy running the roman empire
right
and you know there's there's this um
tendency among a lot of people to read
marcus
as being you know pessimistic a typical
stoic in this way
and otto says no no he's actually not
and there's something here about this
connection to
nature you know the cosmos that that
plays into that
then there's this other great essay that
i i really particularly
uh like and i think it's very important
and on
an interrupted dialogue with michel
foucault convergences and divergences
so adele recognized that foucault was
doing something
similar to what his projects were
were in line with and you know
foucault dies quite young and ado says
it's really too bad
uh we were you know kind of robbed of
the opportunity to go on and we kind of
took it for granted he'd be around
so there's some discussion there about
how he sees things differently from
foucault and where there's continuities
the last part is called ends and
there's this great essay in there the
end of paganism
and you know if you only actually if you
only read one essay in here
read that one because it's such
excellent
history of ideas bringing to light
so many things that go against the
prevailing
wrong-headed orthodoxies of what you
know
what you know ancient uh uh
greece and rome were like and how
christianity sort of
bolds its way in no there's a lot more
continuities
than discontinuities as adults puts out
and then he talks about models of
happiness proposed by the ancient
philosophers
and you know that's a good essay just
discussing
what it is that they thought happiness
looked like and how you
how you get on your way to it so that's
you know i've done a lot of summary
here but also talking about the
structure of the work
and i will point this out too you could
read just
you know one of these essays at a time
they don't presuppose each other it's
not a
developmentally you know arranged work
you could actually start at the end if
you wanted to
with you know the 13th essay or the 14th
essay and continue
on but that's what we have here and i
should mention as well
very good index both of
the texts and of proper names and
there's a really nice
bibliography in here as well
that actually spans it looks like it
spans about 10 pages so very very well
researched work
here and that contributes to the value
of this this text
i think i've already mentioned a few of
the key ideas that you're going to find
in this book but i should mention
one that is absolutely overarching
that ado is is a champion of namely that
philosophy as it was practiced in
ancient times running into medieval
times
and even emerging as such in some modern
authors should be understood as
a way of life rather than merely as an
academic theoretical pursuit and to
understand it as a way of life
isn't some sort of wishy-washy new agey
oh you know we have to apply this sort
of thing
it was rather that the the what was that
what was being taught and what was being
done was a complex
body of what ado calls spiritual
exercises of a number of different sorts
oftentimes
borrowed from or running in parallel to
those of other schools
and these were to transform a person
gradually by stages incrementally into
somebody
who could fully realize human nature and
enjoy
whatever ended it was that they were
setting themselves freedom happiness
you know not being troubled by things
and it was also very often connected
with
you know restoring or achieving
a interconnection between oneself
and the cosmos so that is really
a key conception it's not it's not
philosophy as a way of life as you know
how to be successful and influence
people and make a lot of money
although that could be part of you know
what's being studied you know especially
in terms of the rhetoric
it's not philosophy as a way of life you
know where you just withdraw from
yourself and find a way to cope with
your your crappy existence
it's something more robust and that was
what was going
on in ancient philosophy at least a lot
of the time
and it made its way into at least
according to adult
early medieval thought although he
thinks that there's there's an
end that gets brought to this at a
certain point by
on the one hand philosophy becoming
subordinated to theology
and by you know the development of
scholasticism
which arguably you know he's quite right
there there's a lot of scholastic
philosophy that's you know just being
done for its own sake
and he also thought that the
incorporation here's where i think he's
actually wrong
about this of some of the ancient
philosophy into monastic life
um turn spiritual exercises into
something
radically different and that's that's a
quibble that we can talk about a little
bit later on
so that that's a really important um key
idea
i'll say another thing too ado
is trying to bring back something
trying to resuscitate an understanding
of philosophy in a
very robust way that is
deeply informed by study
of the ancient thinkers and their their
texts what we have available and
references to them in other thinkers and
texts so that i think is is really a key
aspect you can't do philosophy as a way
of life
just by you know making flash cards for
yourself and having a bunch of listicles
or sound bites or something like that
it's not the way you can do stoicism or
epicureanism or
cynicism or any of those those sorts of
things
there's a lot of of key points that he
brings out in here about particular
dimensions and about
what different schools were doing so you
can learn quite a lot about that through
through reading this
um i would say that another key idea
here is that the philosophical exercises
or you know spiritual exercises to use
his term they
are they are being developed within
contexts
that go beyond just the exercises
themselves
and they can be stripped out of that
context but they lose
a lot when when you do that
the history of thought for ado is
you know very complex he avoids
any of the sort of schematic approaches
to history that you see a lot of
kind of second-rate historians doing
where you know the middle ages is the
age of faith and so we can generalize
about that
a doe is one of those thinkers who's
like no we you know we actually need to
go and like
read and see what if we're going to make
claims about bernard of clairvaux
we've got to go read the guy and see
what he's doing and we have to think
about the milieu in which he is
writing and we also have to think about
what his life was like
so on the one hand he's doing really
good history
of philosophy on the other hand he's not
doing history of philosophy in an
antiquarian way where he's like well we
need to figure this out
just so we can like you know do a
conference presentation about
you know this this person here and this
this monastery
he wants to say this could be actual
stuff that we could do
in the present we could you know recover
this
and we could take on the path of the
stoics or
the path of you know these these early
christian writers we could even do it
with
descartes you know there's there's a
great point in here
where he says that um descartes
meditations really need to be read as
meditations here we go um this is
in um the
essay uh in uninter
interrupted dialogue with michel
foucault convergences and divergences
so he tells us that um and this is
actually a good good thing to bring up
the
the other point that i i had my position
is that the rupture occurred in the
middle ages at the moment when
philosophy becomes auxiliary to theology
and when spiritual exercises are
integrated into christian spirituality
becoming independent of the
philosophical life modern philosophy has
rediscovered little by little
and only ever partially the ancient
conception of philosophy
foucault by contrast makes descartes
responsible for this rupture
and in his his great way of framing
things
uh after summing up what foucault has to
say
uh dough says i am not completely sure
that this is exact which is the french
way of saying i think this is completely
wrong
and he says descartes is written
precisely
meditations and this word is very
important concerning these meditations
descartes advises his readers to
dedicate a number of months or at least
a number of weeks to meditate the first
and second meditations
in which he speaks of universal doubt
and then of the nature of the mind
this clearly shows that for descartes
evidence can only be recognized on the
basis of a spiritual
exercise so you know i think this is
really you know
quite good um this is a key idea that
these spiritual exercises
do show up in modern philosophy in other
works you know a doe talks about the
existentialists or
he mentions schopenhauer in here as well
so
i think that that's quite good another
thing that i think is is an important
key point
is uh doe criticizes what at the time
were called the structural
approach people in the history of
philosophy are like well listen all
we've got
are the texts let's not go outside of
the text victor goldschmidt would be a
good example of this
who's quite interesting to read but you
know ado is taking us
further by saying no no we we can
actually think about what it was like to
live this stuff out you know what what
would have been plato's oral teaching
you know
what what would have been going on
within the academy as best as we can
tell
so those are all some some important
points
i would say that are made we could
probably go on and on here in this video
could get very long
if we were to try to add more of them so
i'll cap
this right here
there are a number of really good points
about this work i'm
only going to give you a selection of
them because i don't want to go on too
long about that
first of all i'm going to say that this
is a
very well arranged work and
i think it's a great translation very
readable
without compromising any rigor
you know without trying to dumb things
down
i myself might be a little bit of a
biased
interpreter when it comes to that
because i am an academic and have been
reading these things but for me this
seems like the sort of thing
that an ordinary person could pick up
and make their way through
without being handicapped by the
diction or or style of writing here
there are a lot of references to
various philosophers mostly from
antiquity
but you know there's this great um
you know bibliography in the back that i
think will
put people on the right path when it
comes to that i'd also like to say
about a doe himself that
part of what i really like about his
works in general
and about this selection
is that he travels down paths
that if you if you haven't done much
work in ancient philosophy or much
reading in ancient philosophy
these are going to be new to you and
he's a reliable guide
and if you have and you've gone
along these these routes he brings to
light for you
new connections or things that you
saw but didn't really pay close
attention to
in the past he's like having
you know an expert guide who who
essentially grew up within
an ancient city and can show you around
and is is willing to take the time to go
down
all the little paths and knows the the
people who can like get you to the back
of the museum or
all those sorts of things and here's the
really interesting thing about this that
i want to say about edo
he's not an esotericist right there's no
like secret teaching
or anything like that it's all stuff
that's actually in plain view
but somebody has to put in the time and
work
to notice it and to draw the connections
and then to shed light on it
and and that is in some respects some of
the genius
of this guy i know he's very very good
at doing that
sometimes he's putting things into
frameworks where you're a little bit
dubious about the framework itself but
the references to what is actually being
said you know he's not leading you
astray so i i think that that is really
quite remarkable you know he is a
historian's historian and
i'll say this again too there's ways of
doing history of philosophy
where you're you know trying to trace
out well who influenced who and what is
this person saying
and that's where you stop a doe doesn't
do that a dough
frames these things as if any one of
them
any one of their doctrines any one of
their spiritual exercises
could be a possibility for us the
readers
in the present so it's it's quite
exciting and i think you can kind of get
that from the way i'm talking about that
to read some of this this uh
stuff through um he opens up all sorts
of really great
new horizons for us he stresses
interconnections
and he also does really good comparative
work
um you know he'll he'll bring up what
the neoplatonists were doing and say
well this is a little bit different than
you know what the middle or
early platonists were doing and the
aristotelians were doing this the cynics
were doing this the stoics are doing
this
here's how they're similar here's how
they're different from each other
here's what's changing in the process
really solid comparative work that i
think could provide
an excellent model for developing
scholars or people who want to practice
philosophy as a way of life or learn
more about
ancient philosophy in the present um
as i mentioned he brings up descartes
he's willing to
say in the in the you know modern period
or even you know in the late modern
period that there are people doing this
philosophy is a way of life it's not
something that was just like you know
ancient times and then now we're going
to bring it forward into the present
it's something that keeps emerging
within philosophy
and he's very attuned to not trying to
blur everything into
everything else but to show connections
dissimilarities
uh parallelisms all those sorts of
things how different
people handle different ideas so you
know some
classic examples the last essay about
what is happiness
or the essay about who is the sage and
what does it mean to be the sage
or you know how do spiritual exercises
get developed and and applied
so those are some really uh
great things it almost goes without
saying that
ado is somebody who has really
put in the time and work to
get to know i won't say master because
you don't really
master philosophical bodies of work what
you do
is you become conversant with them in a
very
intimate way where you you know what
that author
is up to you might not actually
completely agree with them but you can
appreciate
what they're doing that definitely comes
through
for ado and you get the sense that he is
somebody who
really did put in the time in his
studies
in continuing on afterwards and you know
i wasn't actually thinking about this
but in a way
if you can see that aspect of a dough it
kind of models
what a good philosopher in in the
present would look like
as well certainly in in my field of
history of philosophy and philosophy
as a way of life so those are some
really
you know outstanding points about the
work that i think
you know justify you wanting to to get
it and read it
i don't know that i would actually say
there's bad points
or things that i find problematic in the
sense of saying i don't like that
about the work but there are a few
things where
i i think it could be good to to mention
some motifs or some some potential
issues
so one of them is
that you know this is
i think really you could put this in
just about anybody's hands but there may
be some readers
that this this just isn't that appealing
to
because they're not that interested in
you know
all these ins and outs of ancient
philosophy but again if you're if you're
doing
study of epicureanism or stoicism or
cynicism or any of these
ancient ways of life and trying to apply
them in the present
maybe that's actually not that much of a
concern maybe you really should get this
book
and work your way through it you're
certainly going to learn something
so actually that's not a problematic
point after all
i i mentioned i don't really agree with
ado's
take on medieval christianity
i would agree with it to some degree but
i would say that
you know monastic way of life was
considered philosophia
and i would say that they expanded the
domain of of
you know what philosophy was i i would
agree with him when it comes to
you know like scholasticism but
understanding scholasticism
as something that that's developing in
certain areas and that some authors like
for example saint anselm is not a
scholastic in that sense he's a monastic
author
who also is kind of suey generous you
know
his own thing that's a minor point i
would say
i i also think that he maybe
oversells how the aristotelians and
and plato were you know providing a way
of life
in in their works again
not a total disagreement with him on
that but it's it's not quite what say
the stoics or epicureans or
later neoplatonists were doing um
but it it's something worth bringing up
and i also
will mention that in you know there is a
tendency to treat a doe
as if he's like you know doing something
new
in talking about philosophy as a way of
life and identifying that and
losing the context of 20th century
french philosophy in which there were a
lot of other figures
doing that prior to edo just not using
the exact terminology
among who might include etienne gilson
gabriel marcel
maurice blondell you know totally
attuned to that
jacques leclerc when it comes to
monastic literature i would say is doing
something kind of similar
but those are you know kind of kind of
quibbles
none of which are particularly important
definitely not damning when it comes to
the work maybe just
signaling where we could have gone a
little bit further with it but
anybody can raise those sorts of issues
so maybe
i'll just say those are all very minor
points
all right my final thoughts on the
selected writings of pirado philosophy
is practice
translated by matthew sharp and
federico testa really good job
on this work both in terms of adobe's
own work that they have brought together
and then you know translated well worth
getting i unqualifiedly
say that you should you should get your
hands on this book if you have any
interest in these sorts of topics
whether it's ancient philosophy
um philosophy is a way of life uh
pierre audeaux himself you you want this
and one of the other things that
occurred to me as i was preparing to
talk about this this actually could be
you could you could give this as the
first book of ado
that somebody should read this could be
an introduction to ado
and then you know you could read his
other works
after that because it covers
so many important aspects of his work
and these are real you know serious
essays here
so this is you know this is quite an
achievement i think that the the
translators
and slash editors are to be uh
commended on on bringing this out i
think this is going to be very helpful
for a number of people uh hopefully
it'll get them more into
ado and other people like ado like you
know for example you know foucault gets
mentioned
nussbaum gets mentioned alistair
mcintyre should be mentioned
and you know there's so many others as
well so
i think that this is uh really quite an
excellent
work and i highly recommend it
you